6 13 it is a monday morning and it's
time to kick off our
special series conquering the quarantine
yeah we'll have reports all week on how
you and all of us here on good day
are learning about new hobbies and side
hustles
as we try and get through this pandemic
well nate gets us started with
a little home cooking what you cooking
up nate all right sherry so i did find a
personal twist for the
condiments section of our fridge and
we'll get to that
but you know i think we all want to
support the struggling restaurant
industry especially locals but it does
seem that many of us are spending
more time in our own kitchens these days
[Applause]
i had a conversation with local chef
lorraine moss from the podcast
two sharp chefs and a microphone even
though we have you know
restaurants kind of open right now and
we have to go
um they might sometimes feel safer or
honestly just they feel like it's easier
because they can find things in their
pantry she showed me a yummy
90-second recipe called comfort cake
in a cup you just need some sort of mug
i like a wide brim one so i can see my
cake and i have more space to eat
a little bit of cooking spray simple
ingredients 1 4 cup of cake flour
2 tablespoons of cocoa powder two to
three tablespoons of sugar
1 4 teaspoon of baking powder 1 4 cup of
milk
1 4 teaspoon of vanilla 2 tablespoons of
vegetable oil canola oil simple process
and then we're just gonna mix it up i
like to give it a good mix
and feel free to lick the bowl as well
and the spatula
then the special part at the end here
it's gonna make it nice and moist and
chocolatey in the middle
i use dark chocolate chips about one
tablespoon
microwave super easy pop it in
i go one minute and 15 seconds
with easy ways to make it your own you
can go sprinkles
you could go red hots mint and chips
look at that
it's just like give it a shot there
lorraine super chocolaty um
it's very very warm so be careful about
that oh can't wait to try it but first
i had to show off that i've learned a
fancy culinary science term
from a cooking show chef who made her
own mayonnaise in a blender
so the mayo is gonna start thickening
and emulsifying
i learned the word emulsify you're a
scientist
you're a meteorologist aren't you nate
emulsify that's an easy one that's it
lorraine inspired me to wonder what it
might be like
if i had my own cooking
show hi welcome to the bowtie nate home
kitchen where today we're making
super hot spicy mayonnaise out of these
simple ingredients they're all going to
go in the blender
two egg yolks one whole egg one
tablespoon of mustard spicy dijon
whatever this is horseradish
three tablespoons of lime juice we got
half a jalapeno
two habaneros one teaspoon of minced
garlic
and one reaper pepper one
ghost pepper this is half a cup of
vegetable oil one cup
of olive oil so you put all of this in
here
and you have it on for one minute on
low okay so this has been a little over
a minute
now here's the key when you pour in the
oil
you have to do it very slowly because
that leads to
a process called emulsification that's
what makes it
into the mayonnaise don't pour it in all
at once
just a slow trickle okay now we're going
to go
with a cup of olive oil and increase the
speed
and you can see how it's thickened up so
we're going to pour it all out
want to waste anything so this is going
to go over to the mixer and whip
for five minutes we're gonna whip it
we're gonna whip it good
all right we've had our five minutes
there's your super spicy
homemade mayonnaise i'm gonna cheat
don't tell anybody
it's not even as hot as the last time i
made it
[Music]
so i brought some of these super hot
spicy mayonnaise in here for anyone that
might want to try it
but i also wanted to really talk more
about chef lorraine because we talked a
lot more
and i have our entire zoom interview
posted online because she talked about
the different types of flour you can use
sugar substitutes you can use and how
folks really are cooking
more at home during the pandemic anybody
want to try the super hot spicy mayo
i do with something cool to chase it
with are those doritos
uh they're fritos fritos we can do that
nate i think you would do so well with
the cooking show i loved that
oh well thank you it was great made in
the kitchen i can see it already
the bow tie and ate home kitchen
[Laughter]
really good nate well you know some of
us native tried to cook during
quarantine
and it doesn't go as well as